thank you
this is Earth
there's Venus Mercury and the Sun
now even though Mercury is twice as
close to the Sun as Venus Venus is the
hotter Planet why carbon dioxide AKA CO2
Venus's atmosphere is full of CO2 and
the greenhouse effect has run amok
since the Industrial Revolution Earth's
CO2 levels have been increasing sharply
and now we too are heating up granted
Earth's been hotter before and colder
but it's been about the same temperature
for the last 10 000 years which includes
all of modern human achievement
like farming pinatas and frequent flyer
miles
climate change is happening
is it fixable
what are the solutions
who's working on this
foreign
there are truly problems that we can't
solve we don't yet have the cure to
cancer we don't yet have the cure for
Alzheimer's we don't yet have the cure
for Parkinson's Disease this problem we
can solve and there's no good reason not
to and so much is at stake
uncheck global warming threatens to
drive into Extinction one out of every
two creatures on the face of the Earth
The Artsy could literally disappear in
10 years time we're going to see serious
disruption of Agriculture huge sea level
rises Millions fleeing to Higher Ground
more extreme storm events wildfires more
periods of drought ethnic conflicts
potential Decline and collapse of
civilization
I've heard enough I'm convinced I don't
need to hear any more about we're all
doomed we know it's a big task but it's
also a fantastic and huge opportunity
[Music]
the U.S has about five percent of the
world's people but we create almost a
quarter of the world CO2 CO2 is not the
only greenhouse gas it's just the one
making the most trouble right now
a lot of people worry about climate
change but a third of Americans don't
think humans are the cause
we agree with the 84 percent of
scientists groups of Faith like the
Evangelical climate initiative many
Fortune 500 companies and the Pentagon
that's right
Department of Defense
these groups know humans are the cause
and that this is a big big problem
figuring out whether tackling climate
change is possible is the big question
they got the job done we better find
people who are giving it the good fight
and hope the next generation is up to
the task
there is a big stumbling block today
there's no cost for emitting CO2 no
penalty for the downside of carbon-based
energy and that makes it hard to move
people to clean the energy
now back to those scientists it's
important to note that many times
they've been wrong with their climate
models global warming is happening much
faster than any of them predicted and
that look us up
so we hit the road huffing hoping for
Solutions
our first stop
wind
[Music]
is a renewable resource it also renews
lives in Pennsylvania's rejuvenated Rust
Belt laid off Steel Workers are now
hired to make turbines
and down in West Texas wind is turning
dirt into gold
are you getting lots of wind noise here
just
that's supposed to be you know that's
supposed to fit right in the picture
wind noise and when you wind farm
[Music]
Cliff saw wind turbines popping up all
around his cotton farm and decided to
get a piece of the action before it blew
away all of the developers that I
approached initially were accustomed to
doing business in the large ranches
lots of land one or two owners my father
felt that if you look around the area
around here most of the land is owned by
small family farmers and the last 20 or
30 years have been difficult for family
farmers and that was the primary reason
why he became interested in trying to
get a wind development project we had
lots owners and lots of small tracts of
land and there was a natural resistance
doing all that contract stuff but once I
was able to convince the developers that
the actual construction cost on this
wonderful flat Farmland with County
Roads everywhere would be an absolute
minimum then they began to take notice
and and was able to make this happen you
might could say I did it all
single-handedly see
I got caught in a cotton stripper in
1972. I was 30 years old
it really wasn't such a traumatic
situation for me I just decided that
I was going to take it on as a challenge
and uh worked out okay
I've been very fortunate
I think that global warming is is
readily accepted and most farmers are
good stewards of the land and they're
wanting to say something done about it
and contribute to it
look at that
is that something
before the turbans things were Bleak in
Roscoe when I graduated from high school
I mean most of the people that uh that
grew up here they couldn't wait to get
out of town and and go to the big city
not because they didn't love this area
but mainly because there were so few
opportunities
for Roscoe I guess we bottomed out when
we lost our Dairy Queen
oh yeah that's the kiss of death for a
small town when your Dairy Queen closes
down you're you're on your last leg but
about that time our wind industry came
along and it's been a fantastic
unbelievable booned Roscoe
frasco's got what will end up being for
a little while at least the largest wind
farm in the world and there are 400
landowners in this area that are sharing
in the benefit of that project the
landowners get paid on the actual amount
of electricity generated their payment
is a straight royalty and this is the
only time they've ever had a chance to
receive a steady income once it's
completed Cliff's Wind Farm will power
250 000 homes and the farmers are raking
in up to fifteen thousand dollars per
turbine per year leasing their land
which is still usable for farming and
ranching
the thing that's really cool you talk to
a lot of the families that raised kids
here and you find out that a large
percentage of them have children moving
back to this area because of the wind
industry Vicki uh Haynes really
benefited from this wind farm I hope I
hope you'll include her she's a lot
better looking than I am this this is
our daughter and our little grandson
that it brought home
and my son-in-law and her little
grandson
so Dan's the one working with the wind
turbines and it's just been a blessing
Farmers really do appreciate these
things this is strictly dry land we sit
here and Pray For Rain and cuss the wind
now what we've been cussing all these
years turned out to be a blessing
[Music]
it's clear wind power reduces cussing in
West Texas but in many other states
people don't like wind turbines or the
transmission lines they'll need that's
too bad because the U.S department of
energy says wind from Texas North and
South Dakota Kansas and Montana as more
power potential than all the electricity
needed in the U.S
if you look at wind's power potential
worldwide it has the capacity to produce
trillions of Watts otherwise known as
Tara Watts
all day every day humans are now using
energy at a rate of 16 terawatts and
this runs everything cars skyscrapers
chips smelters crock pots everything
with electricity fuels cow dung you name
it a terawatt is a trillion Watts
100 Watts power is a 100 watt light bulb
a kilowatt is a thousand Watts
an average American household consumes
28 kilowatts of the terawatt five a
billion watts is a gigawatt
Seattle or San Francisco eat up at least
a gigawatt of power a thousand gigawatts
is a terawatt and as soon as possible we
need all 16 of those terawatts to come
from clean climate safe sources We Now
power less than two terawatts that way
getting to 16 terawatts will be a tough
task let's say two terawatts will be
made from wind power we'd have to build
and install one large wind turbine every
five minutes for the next 25 years
is that even possible at its peak
General Motors could make six new cars
every minute and many car factories sit
idle
let's retool and build wind turbines
and check this out every day 86 000
terawatts hit the earth as solar power
over 32 terawatts are pumping from
geothermal power and 870 terawatts of
wind power are blowing around the globe
right now
we only need 16.
although wind turbines are sprouting
like mushrooms across the West
cold plants are popping up even faster
in the east
[Applause]
years in China they're going to build
800 000 megawatts into coal plants
that's two and a half times more plants
than we have installed in the U.S today
although we are now Nick and Nick with
the Chinese as to who is the biggest
polluter we should realize that in terms
of what's heating the Earth what's up
there now it's 80 or 85 percent Western
pollution
now the first challenge we in the west
have is not to be smuck
we have no right to say we should wait
until they do something for us to do
something that's just wrong Point number
two is it is in our economic
self-interest because if we don't get
going all the other countries are going
to get going there's no question that
these Technologies are going to grow
very quickly the question is who's going
to get the business we've already seen
that U.S has lost a solar business solar
energy was basically commercialized in
the United States now the biggest solar
companies are in Japan and Germany the
biggest wind turbine companies again we
created that industry are in Denmark in
Germany if we don't get off the dime and
start moving aggressively ahead to
become the leaders in this vast vibrant
new renewable energy field China is
likely to be there well ahead of us
their automobile fuel efficiency
standards are tougher than ours are and
they've got a half a dozen of the most
vibrant fast-growing solar full of
voltaic electric companies in the world
what we need to be worried about is
whether whether or not we're keeping up
with them my Approach is to make America
the country that gets respected Rich
secure entrepreneurial and competitive
by Leading the world in clean power and
Energy Efficiency the next great Global
industry the good thing about the green
economy the clean energy economy the low
carbon economy it's a labor-intensive
economy it will create an infinite
amount of jobs this is geostrategic
geoeconomic It's the Most patriotic
thing you can be do think or feel today
green baby is the new red white and blue
thank you
climate changes in fact a national
security issue we need to change how we
think about this
[Music]
we're in tree Hunters not that there's
anything wrong
climate change is posing risks around
the world
foreign
from the increasing risk of extreme
weather events to sea level rise as
Deltas get flooded worldwide and there
are a lot of very highly populated
Deltas you can think Mississippi you can
think Ganges you can think Nile
are those people are going to have to
move the world is not ready to accept
all those refugees so they're going to
be a lot of wars or nearly Wars and
should they occur in some parts of the
world where the United States has very
significant presence and interest you'll
have a security problem that affects the
United States but there are closer and
more more critical elements that affect
security fundamentally we all understand
we've got to get off our dependency on
foreign
the nations in the Middle East are more
important now because of our desire for
oil if you take that out of the equation
then
maybe the kind of spectrum of conflict
we see ourselves in over there may
change president to George H.W bush
would probably not have felt he had to
protect Saudi Arabia from Iraq the
Persian Gulf had been told that
two-thirds of the world's proven supply
of broccoli
[Music]
I was not a big believer in global
warming but you can only read so many
reports so much science you know I live
in Florida and I was going to say drill
drill drill
but now as I know more about this I
think that
if oil is the problem maybe more oil is
not the answer
at 300 000 barrels a day the Department
of Defense is one of the world's biggest
users of oil
getting that fuel to the front lines is
incredibly expensive
in dollars
but more importantly in blood
when you're moving large convoys of
thin-skinned vehicles transporting fuel
our enemies clearly understand how
critical that is to us and that is what
they will attack
we have to find ways to as as one Marine
General likes to say unleash ourselves
from the tether of fuel then the
military won't need to fight over oil
and the war Fighters as you can imagine
really like that idea
current green hawk and career badass Dan
Nolan headed up a task force to figure
out ways to reduce military oil use
early on we wanted to understand what
was the real problem what was the real
Challenge and so we went out we started
visiting some of the Ford operating
bases the fobs a third of the Army's
wartime fuel use is to run generator
sets to make electricity in a typical
forward operating base recently examined
95 percent of that electricity went to
air conditioned inefficiently tents
sitting in a very hot sandy place if it
was 120 degrees with the air
conditioning blowing in there you might
be able to get it down to 100 degrees
and really what we're doing is we're
conditioning the desert so we're getting
people blown up in fuel convoys to
deliver the fuel to be wasted in that
way just connect the dots and obviously
there's something wrong with this
picture
we looked at what was currently
available in terms of adding liners to
tents and that sort of things and then
one of the folks on my team came up with
the idea of spray foam insulation this
looks like a tent the only difference
it doesn't move
at all essentially you've got a big
eagle of cooler here
by foaming tents we go from a 50 ton
cooling unit down to a eight ton cooling
unit which reduces our power consumption
tremendously we figured that within
approximately 10 months we will pay for
everything so we're actually saving
soldiers lives giving a more comfortable
place to stay and saving money and
saving the environment all in that one
Fell Swoop
the untense quickly constructed
buildings that use no fuel are on the
horizon what we're in right now is a
monolithic dome that has its own power
we have two wind turbines and two solar
panels the goal is to get continuous
flow into the batteries inside what we
really don't have right now is utility
level power storage that for me is the
Holy Grail
if the green Hawks get the dod to invest
in large-scale Battery Technology they
could help jump start an industry when
the first microchip came out it was very
very expensive
until Uncle Sam started investing in
them and those prices went down and it
became commercially viable we could use
the government's buying power
to make these systems more accessible on
the commercial Market
[Music]
our mission in protecting our nation and
close protecting our environment
and sometimes outside Society follows in
the footsteps of the military Harry S
Truman ordering the integration of the
Armed Forces helped kick-start civil
rights in the 60s because all those
soldiers who lived with people of
different color and race you know in the
military went home and changed their
communities when the military goes green
the country is going to go green
but right now even as the green Hawks
ranks are growing
trenched bureaucracy of the dod is
pushing back hard against innovation
it's going to take many more bold
military leaders and brave lawmakers to
give this lasting traction
for years now we've been hearing about
climate change as some far-off event
finding Solutions was smart but we
thought we had time to figure things out
trouble is there's no more time the
evidence is piling high that climate
change is happening right now
[Music]
the consequences of climate change are
being acutely felt in the Cascade
Mountains of Washington State
warmer winter temperatures which they've
got cause more precipitation to fall as
rain not snow
more winter rains mean water becomes
storm runoff instead of slowly
recharging the groundwater as snowmelt
does
less snow means glaciers aren't
replenished all this adds up to wasted
water in Winter and droughts in summer
lowering the output of Washington's main
source of electricity hydropower and
greatly reducing the numbers of salmon
as well
in the last 60 years 53 glaciers have
disappeared on the Northern Cascades
Glaciers are also retreating in the
Sierras the Rockies the Alps and the
Himalayas hundreds of millions of people
and thousands of Industries rely on that
water
[Music]
as the country gears up for a green
tomorrow
a major place of change is on the road
[Music]
the world's Transportation runs on
carbon-rich fossil fuels lessening The
Thirst for fuel comes in many shapes and
sizes Landing cities so people can walk
ride their bikes and take mass transit
as a great start
loading trucks more efficiently using
only one engine when taxiing cleanse
even tacking a sale on cargo ships all
reduce carbon dioxide which from cars
trucks trains planes and ships adds up
to about 14 percent of all the world CO2
and as more and more fuel is needed
across the globe using fuel more
efficiently is key
I'm a truck driver I'm out on the road
10 11 hours a day seven days a week I
try to take at least a day off here and
there see the family stop by the house
see the bills that they're piling up
I run from California all the way to
Texas you're running temperatures
between uh 95 to 110 degrees and the
coldest four days ago the temperature
was 24 degrees
to run their air conditioners or heaters
while they sleep the truckers have to
keep their engines running we were
burning about one gallon per hour even
if it's during the winter or during the
summer
so we idle I mean some sense up to seven
to nine to ten hours so you basically
are losing uh dollars you're losing
dollars every time that truck is running
and not moving
the solution to this is the external
power unit which cools the truck with a
tiny bit of battery power and heats the
truck with one tenth the fuel
you can sit there and get frosting you
can lay down and get Frosty my heaters
over here that works together with this
unit hot air will start popping up from
the bottom of that vent and you'll start
getting everything nice and warm I'm
able to conserve my fuel then I can
travel longer distances without sitting
there idling 9-10 hours you know burning
the 19 gallons this 9 10 gallons is
going to give me x amount of mileage you
know it adds up so yeah there's
somebody's vacation right there
we don't know about the world but if all
long-haul truckers in America shut their
engines off while they slept they would
reduce CO2 emissions by 11 million tons
and save more than 1 billion gallons of
fuel a gear which is over one-fifth the
department of defense's fuel usage
fuel efficiency is critical but we also
need options other than fossil fuels
automobile companies are starting to say
look we want to sell you the cars you
want sometimes they'll be big sometimes
they'll be fast
but we're going to power them on
something other than petroleum products
one replacement for petroleum products
is biofuels now I'm somebody that owns
the ethanol plants in America Corn based
ethanol plants Corn based ethanol plants
and nowhere near as efficient as
sugar-based ethanol perms for every acre
of sugar you can produce seven times
more fuel than one acre of corn
a big drawback to ethanol is that it
can't be refined into diesel the world's
principal Transportation fuel nor can it
make Airplane Fuel ethanol freezes at 15
000 feet and therefore is not a good
idea for planes to have ethanol
we are still in a world that runs on
combustion engines there's over a
million man hours of just engineering
work in a modern jet engine that's not
going to disappear tomorrow so
something's got to feed those jet
engines if we want to continue to move
around the world
we're looking for renewable sustainable
methods for doing that
there's a promising biofuel that uses no
food sources is homegrown and makes both
Diesel and Airplane Fuel
[Music]
if you look at fossil fuels the bulk of
the carbon that we're burning now was
algae derived the beauty of the algae is
renewable on top of being renewable a
clear advantage over fossil fuels a pond
of algae is highly productive if I grow
an acre of corn over the course of a
year and I take that piece of land I
plant as many crops as I can in 12
months the maximum yield that I'll get
out of corn from an oil standpoint is
about 28 gallons if I do the same thing
with an acre of palm trees for producing
palm oil I'll get somewhere between six
and 800 gallons if I scrape that acre of
land off put a shallow pond in it
without any technology just an open Pond
I can get as high as 5 000 gallons of
oil
the promise of algae is tantalizing like
many new green technologies it's
expensive now but could become cheaper
once pilot projects grow to Big Time
operations
another way to get the oil monkey off
our backs
use electricity first automobiles were
electric then because of the oil was so
cheap and the batteries were ready they
very quickly moved over the gasoline
we've been doing it one way for the last
hundred years but now we've got to be
thinking about what's the technology for
the next hundred years and personally I
believe it's electrification of
Transportation
this is a very complex high-tech
operation
take the extension cord
and you plug it
into the car
all you have to do really for this is to
put in the lithium-ion battery which is
about 10 times more powerful
than the regular battery in the car
although these batteries are not quite
ready for mass production Untold teams
of researchers worldwide are honing in
on the solutions like making them last
10 years and ensuring that they'll be
recyclable
the overall goal is less emissions with
less expense
you're talking about
being able to drive at something close
to 10 percent of the cost of what you're
driving at now now you don't have to be
concerned about climate change or
terrorism or anything to want to drive
it 10 of the cost of what you're driving
at net the net emission reduction for
CO2 is better for plug-in hybrids no
matter what you're using for electricity
even coal plants produce less emissions
through a plug-in hybrid than gasoline
does an internal combustion engine
certainly if you're using wind and solar
and renewable energies you're getting an
enormous reduction in emissions
Pacific Northwest National Laboratories
has done a big study and they say you
could have 85 percent of the cars on the
road be plug-in hybrids before you need
a single new power plant
plug-in hybrids could also solve one of
the Grid's major problems utilities have
no way to store electricity for when
they need it we've got to build power
plants to meet
relatively speaking a few hours a few
days of the year when demand is at the
absolute highest and for the rest of the
time we've got this excess capacity
but with the Advent of plug-in hybrids
this excess capacity could be socked
away in their batteries when we're in a
power crisis and it's a very hot day the
air conditioning load is high and we're
looking at having to turn on more fossil
fuel plants then you could sign up to
say my car is plugged in it's sitting at
work use it as a tiny power plant and
imagine millions of those power plants
being able to feed back into the grid
and we avoid contributing to the carbon
problem because you stored it up
and if the utility wanted to use your
plug-in hybrid for electric storage
you could say beg me
and then pay me
if you go into a dealer showroom in a
couple of years and the salesman says
the local utility we're working on an
arrangement with him but it looks like
within a year or so they may be picking
up about a quarter or so of your annual
car payments
what's not to like about that right
what's not to like is the patchwork of
laws that govern utilities across the
country in some states or even counties
it's against the law for people to sell
extra electricity they generate to
anyone but the utilities
and there's no law that says the
utilities have to buy that electricity
back
to change all that it'll take courageous
lawmakers to put country first and big
utilities second for this great program
could stall out even while climate
change is revving up
[Music]
let's go climate change has already
shortened Winters which means late
formation of sea ice the strong barrier
between Coastal Villages and the violent
Bering Sea winter storms
as the exposed soil is much softer than
sea ice the village of nutuk with 340
residents is losing 80 feet a year of
Coastline their barge Landing the main
source of incoming Goods is gone as is
their dump
their fresh water supply is next to go
they've got to move nine miles Inland
the cost
130 million dollars
four other Villages are also designated
imminently threatened with 184 more on
Deck
foreign
600 miles away and still in Alaska
there's a team fighting climate change
with an untapped energy source that
saves money clears the air and even
warms your bath
[Music]
we're at Chino Hot Springs I'm Bernie
Carl and uh here's Bert and Ernie there
are goats
[Laughter]
[Applause]
Alaska has more geothermal energy than
all the states put together but yet
China Hot Springs is the first
geothermal power plant in the state of
Alaska Gwen Holden is Bernie's chief
engineer for energy projects I'm
pregnant with uh twins right now that's
right six months pregnant
[Music]
Quinn's main job with Bernie was
exploring the potential of the China Hot
Springs themselves what people were
saying was that the 165 degree
Fahrenheit water that we had wasn't high
enough for generating power your typical
geothermal plant is operated at 250 F or
greater so you're really looking for
very hot water or even steam I knew that
I could make electricity from this water
and I brought in a drill rig and I
started drilling a well over here before
long Bernie and Gwen did a successful
test at the same time way back in
Connecticut giant manufacturer UTC power
was working on the same solution we
needed 165 200 degree water when you go
to China Hot Springs there's 165 degree
water coming out of the ground that's
where Bernie Carl comes in
now this power plant is making power off
of water that's not as hot as McDonald's
coffee we developed lower temperature
technology so you don't have to go after
300 or 400 degree water or steam this is
working we're doing it I mean
the lights are on right now geothermally
now we're going to enter the largest ice
structure in the world to be up all
summer now Forbes Magazine voted this
the dumbest business idea of the Year Mr
Forbes can kiss my ass
this entire structure has kept cold
geothermally
it cost me about 12 dollars a day to
refrigerate this place if you did it on
diesel fuel standard it would be 750 a
day
it's the cheapest thing going our
electricity was costing us 30 cents a KW
right now we're at five cents a KW in
three to four years will be one penny
per kilowatt hour we'll have the
cheapest energy in the state of Alaska
people say where do you stand on global
warming I said well if someone thinks
there's not global warming then they
must have their head up their ass I said
if you pull your head out and open your
eyes you'll notice the Glaciers are
melting you will notice that the sea ice
cap is almost gone so do you think
there's global warming
yes there is do I think man is causing
global warming I think that we add to it
do I think we're causing it no but that
doesn't make any difference I want clean
water and I want clean air and that's so
simple
usually what I get is people say well
why hasn't this been done before I don't
know
I have no idea
if I can do it here maybe it'll catch on
to the other 230 villages in Alaska and
maybe if it catches on there what if it
starts catching on in the towns what if
everybody caught on what if they did it
because it made sense in their pocket
what if they had more change at the end
of the day for being responsible
what about that
[Music]
climate change Maybe hardest on the
ocean where hundreds of millions of
people get their main source of protein
off the coast of Oregon is a dead zone
the size of New Jersey
thousands and thousands of Dungeness
crabs see worms and sea stars have died
because oxygen levels are so low
pockets of oxygen depleted seawater have
long been common far offshore but with a
combination of climate change-induced
fluctuations in currents and winds the
most severe low oxygen conditions ever
observed on the west coast are now
plaguing marine life
climate modeling predicted what has
become an annual occurrence since 2002.
scientists have no idea whether this is
reversible
[Music]
Energy Efficiency is getting the
services you need like a Cobia or hot
shower or a comfortable house using as
little cargo and generating fuel as
possible
[Music]
thank you
Energy Efficiency starts with buildings
which account for about 40 percent of
all U.S greenhouse gas emissions which
has more than double that of
transportation and that's because we use
a lot of fuel oil and natural gas to
heat buildings we use electricity to
light them and cool them currently a bit
of this electricity comes from
Renewables but a big chunk comes from
natural gas and nuclear nuclear power
splits atoms and opinions proponents
tout its ability to produce massive
amounts of non-carbon energy opponents
have distaste for radioactive waste
potential for rogue nuclear bombs made
from that waste and the enormous cost
for new nuclear plants
there is disagreement on whether nuclear
power is a must in tackling climate
change but right now one other energy
source has the Lion's Share of the
market
we're looking right now at a U.S
electricity business that's about 50
percent cold
and the fact is coal is the dirty dirty
fossil fuel there's no debating that it
is absolutely the dirtiest fossil fuel
laughs
nobody has figured out on a large scale
commercial scale how to strip out CO2
from the emission stream and more
importantly I haven't figured out where
we put it if we strip it out
Home Depot has a wonderful program they
funded the planting of 300 000 trees
already and are planning on funding more
and as a tree grows it sequesters carbon
Ed and I started running the numbers and
we were shocked a single medium-sized
coal plant in 10 days of operation
completely negates those 300 000 trees
over 100 Year lifetime
so that was a real eye-opener and kind
of made us sick to our stomach to be
honest with you
so Ed and Christina formed the
non-profit group architecture 2030.
by 2030 most buildings will be new or
renovated
they say if we urge lawmakers to raise
the bar on efficient building standards
making all those new and used buildings
super low energy users we won't even
need coal by 2030 and all it will take
is to ratchet up the technology we have
in hand
if we were to shift to the most
efficient Lighting Technologies now on
the market we can cut electricity use
worldwide by 12 percent
[Music]
that would enable us to close 705 of the
world's nearly 2 400 coal-fired power
plants
[Music]
if every New Yorker swapped out all of
the light bulbs in his or her apartment
for CFLs we could run the subway system
on the savings
foreign
gotta love this commute huh
[Music]
these are beautiful
so bright
kind of feels like we're on a prairie
here with the grasses behind me a lot of
Illinois species but we're actually 12
stories above street level we're on the
roof of City Hall and this was our first
experience with the green roof
the temperature on a green roof is about
80 or 90 degrees in the summer whereas
the temperature on a black roof can be
up to 160 170 degrees
I can feel the heat emanating from this
other black roof over here
so bringing that temperature down on the
roof surface makes it easier to air
condition inside but it also keeps the
ambient environment around the building
cooler which reduces air conditioning
costs for your neighbors
we calculated that if we can reduce the
temperature in the City by one degree we
can save 150 million dollars a year on
air conditioning costs
as effective as green roofs are there's
something even more valuable and cheaper
too I'd like to see what color the roof
is it should be white in this climate
we have a lot of coal being burned in
power plants to run air conditioners to
take away the heat that wouldn't be in
the buildings in the first place if they
had light-colored grooves
besides cooling the Earth by reducing
cold use white roofs also help cool the
Earth by reflecting sunlight making up
for the ever decreasing amount of sea
ice that used to reflect sunlight
by the time you got all the roots white
you would be cooling the Earth
equivalent to having grabbed 24 billion
tons of CO2 out of the air which is
equivalent to tapping global warming for
the next seven years it's it's huge
architect Bob Fox and Company have added
up a few energy efficient benefits of
their own in the Bank of America
building
we're using about half the energy of a
typical building of this size we're
using half the potable water of a
building this size we did spend a lot of
money to put in the green components of
this building but all of it has a very
short payback period so it's not what
does it cost to do a green building it's
what does it cost not to do it
[Music]
New York City has great new buildings
but 85 percent of the buildings that we
will have in 2030 we already have today
and so if we're really going to make a
dent we've got to do some retrofits
I would like to see some of the effort
transferred into installing real
efficiency for low-income people many of
these apartment buildings are just
dreadfully inefficient and the whole
thought of taking gas and simply blowing
it out uncaulked windows is enough to
make one cry bad economics it's bad
carbon and it's worse for poor people
I see the United States having almost a
full employment Economy based on
retrofitting rebooting a nation
when you renovate a building you're not
going to take that building ship it
overseas renovate it then ship it back
you're going to renovate it on site
we're gonna have to weatherize millions
of buildings that's thousands of
contracts millions of jobs billions of
dollars beginning to flow in a positive
direction to help the United States go
from being the world leader in pollution
to the world leader in Solutions
the Empire State Building is old it has
a lot of complicated details and old
systems the building is is up for some
major technical Renovations anyway
and instead of doing
a normal renovation that makes it nicer
but not more efficient we can do both at
once
we're here at the Empire State Building
today and our goal is to make this
building the most efficient building it
can be we're talking about putting a
shelf that would reflect the sunlight
onto the ceiling
into the space so that it would be
reflected down deeper into the space the
breakthroughs in one area can drive
further breakthroughs in another we're
here to change the rules
for example if we dramatically improve
the building envelope then we can
dramatically downsize The Mechanics for
cooling and heating that means by the
way I pay for a smaller cooling plant I
saved money and my tenants who pay for
the operating expenses of the building
will have a lower occupancy cost
depending on what choices are made we
can save about 38 percent of the energy
and make it a lot more comfortable and
healthy and productive to work in give
it higher real estate value
and I think if we can do such a great
retrofit in the Empire State Building
nobody else has an excuse
remember those 16 terawatts five could
be knocked off the list with our new
friend Energy Efficiency
cheapest fastest and cleanest way to let
coals stay in the ground and out of the
air nothing that we recommend in the
form of energy efficiency costs money it
all saves money so that's a rich field
to mine it's like a Saudi Arabia under
our cities
[Music]
deficiency is a no-brainer but because
it's free to emit CO2 making
carbon-based energy artificially cheap
Energy Efficiency is still routinely
ignored besides buildings that's a huge
mistake in the industrial world in the
industrial setting what happens is lots
of Industrials are throwing away really
really hot gases that they haven't
recaptured as power because they're not
in the power business and that steel
mills you'll see these big flares one
plant over in Northern Indiana takes
that heat and makes 95 megawatts of
power and that's one mill in Northern
Indiana and the amazing thing if you
stay on top of this Mill as you look
around the restaurant in Indiana you can
see flares just look around say oh you
can do another one there you can do
another one there
this electricity made from wasted heat
is one-third the cost of the steel mills
regular electricity
and if we made use of all wastes to
energy opportunities World CO2 emissions
would be reduced by 12 percent maybe
more
I don't know of any bigger opportunity
to make more money reducing more CO2
than this one so if you don't give a
damn about the environment do it because
you're you're a greedy bastard you know
and you just want cheap power
cheap power for most means less power
needed refrigerators under the energy
star program are now one half the price
and use one quarter the energy as their
1975 models
real trick today is how we get rid of
the old ones
this is very typical of the average
fridge we pick up
utility companies have hired us to go
out to customers homes pick these things
up verify that they work bring them in
here and recycle over 95 percent of the
materials that went into making
refrigerators are really bad bad
environmental time loans
CFC 12 which is in the cooling circuit
that's what people typically call Freon
is 10 720 times greater a global warmer
than CO2 we suck out the oil and the
refrigerant and we do that
simultaneously
then you take the polyurethane foam
which is in the insulation in this
refrigerator you have 2.5 tons of CO2
equivalent just in the insulation we did
all this wonderful milling and heating
and all that what we wind up with is
Freon R11 or CFC 11. that is doomed for
Destruction and that's what we do with
it when I was 20 years old I started
producing a rock and roll concerts I did
everybody from Elvis to Sinatra and two
tours with the Rolling Stones everybody
goes well how do you go from Rock and
Roll to refrigerators and I said it was
it was quite easy it involved a jetty
right after I did Rodney Dangerfield's
U.S tour I went surfing after a
hurricane and I hit a jetty and I
actually died I drowned and they brought
me back to life and I decided that I
better do something different as I'm out
there going underwater and I'm going
somewhere else I said you know leave me
on Earth and I'll do something good for
the world and you know what it was a
life-changing event
okay these are uh Grease Monkeys it
looks like
hi Wade let's do it good
every refrigerator we pick up in this
program is like taking two cars off the
road for an entire year 10 tons of CO2
equivalent my father
styrofoam ice chest and some of his
cohorts were actually the people that
were responsible for polyurethane foam
being used so my father was responsible
for putting those things out there and I
got to go clean up their Maps
the mess we're giving our kids to clean
up strange the imagination
in the States along the Rocky Mountains
later and warmer Winters are having a
devastating effect
hundreds of millions of pine trees have
been killed by the tiny pine beetle
once held in check by the now
disappearing winter cold snaps The
Beetles have much more time to ravage
in Helena Montana the kildor forest
surrounds the town and unfortunately the
cost of clearing the timber which they
have to do and then Milling it is more
than the beetle munched wood is worth
in the western U.S over 24 million Acres
of pine trees are dead
and since trees help cool the air
it's looking like their loss could heat
up the interior West even more which
could really hurt the water supply
Agriculture and tourism of an already
stressed out area
[Music]
right now tomorrow too Earth is on the
receiving end of 86 000 terawatts of
solar power
solar panels and Towers aren't cheap yet
but sunlight is free for the taking the
excitement in solar right now are the
forests of mirrors in the desert that
collect solar energy boil water spin
turbines in that sense it's a very
traditional electric generating
technology using the heat of the Sun
instead of the heat of burning fossil
fuels
a drawback to Big solar in the desert is
having to string up city-bound
transmission lines through protected
lands and national forests
popping photovoltaic systems on the
rooftops sidesteps this snake pit what
is so great about this rooftop project
here is that the electricity goes right
to the grid
this will create energy for 165 000
homes and what I like about it to put
this rooftop on created jobs it proves
that you can't protect the environment
and protect the economy at the same time
because of these giant projects coupled
with local and federal tax breaks cost
of solar is going down for homeowners as
well
and for the communities where solar is
still too expensive Van Jones has
dedicated his life to helping folks
afford the panels
by focusing on the people installing the
panels
[Music]
that's Richmond right there tough
tough Scrappy you keep barking that's
good
[Music]
foreign
I was driving back from Marin County
and I've been like a spirituality
Retreat you know you know it's like you
know like not something in my community
and people I was dealing with was really
interested in
and I was driving back over the bridge
I'm thinking I'm going back to Oakland
you know I'm going back to pollution
cancer clusters and just had this this
thing in my mind and I just said you
know we need green jobs not jails those
four words four syllables have just
totally turned my life around because
you know that's that's what I'm about
great alternative is like the Habitat
for Humanity of the solar industry they
are trying to get solar panels up in you
know low-income communities people who
need them
we do the installation for free and then
the homeowners finance a portion of the
equipment cost with a low interest loan
that they get from the city
you want to be sure to win don't blow my
money off the roof so we won't put it in
unless from day one they're gonna have
savings if it doesn't make dollars it
doesn't make sense that's right great
Alternatives they're making sure that
the low-income people who need the solar
panels can get the solar panels and then
solar Richmond make sure that
disadvantaged people get trained to do
the work so it's a two for one
so uh I like have you been a part of
this program
give me my 10th week 10th week is it
good
the best thing that ever happened to me
oh really why you say that because you
know it's a lot of a lot of a lot of
stuff that's going around
the negative yeah negative stuff A lot
of times you know these guys you know
they're on probation they're on parole
you know the probation officer just you
know assumes the worst about him and
then when they see them
blossoming and doing something positive
even they were getting choked up this is
more of a way to Branch out you know get
ahead get a job you know provide for
your family see a lot of times when
people look at urban communities what
they see is deficits they see what's not
there and when I look all I see is
assets I see you know entrepreneurs you
know Visionaries Geniuses Hustlers you
know and that's what we need right now
some Visionary genius Hustlers and now I
can be the owner of my own company and
like you know four or five years six
years you know just by starting at the
bottom you got to start somewhere to
build up to the top so if you want to
have a green economy it's got to be
about reclaiming stuff it's also it'll
be about reclaiming people reclaiming
neighborhoods that's the green economy
usually when I was working I never
thought about my son about the future
now I can think about the future so I'm
working for a cause now
like Daryl van also had a little
motivation besides meeting the younger
Jones
we met the man who showed van what
working for a cause was all about
as my father would say are you reaching
back are you helping somebody you
throwing a rope back now my dad had an
impossible task of you know trying to
fix a school and they gave him five
years he did it in one year I was a
principal
uh they gave me
Jackson junior course which was
supposed to have been the uh
the worst of the worst worst or the
worst and
we turned it around where it was the
best of the best you hear my father's
story it's just so so hopeful that's how
I feel about the country that's how I
feel about this whole planetary crisis I
know the ending I already know the
ending and it's so amazing to think how
discouraged people are and they don't
believe you can do something and then
you show some leadership and have some
hope and you bring out the best in
people I don't have the answers but I
know people do have the answers nobody's
told them you can do it nobody's asked
them you solve it and and and and that's
how you lead that's how I lead
it's the people that nobody's heard from
that are going to solve the problem
maybe in a few years and you'll be able
to see solar panels all over
now the pound's gonna be going out and
the money's going to be staying in the
house that's that's what this is all
about
we helping with the with the environment
now we got the right kind of light bulbs
and then we got solar paneling on the
roof to reduce the energy we making
energy we're sending energy to the
Energy company now we're saving money
right now
who don't get my [__]
I'll let you know
come look at that at the meter
clockwise it's this way right
that's when it you know you're using up
power this is going counterclockwise so
it means we're feeding power into PG e
OS this is the future it's a place for
ordinary people to earn some money and
for low-income people to save some money
that's gonna be the green economy to
save the world
[Music]
all of these clean energies and energy
efficiencies cut down carbon emissions
in huge numbers
together they come back four-fifths of
man-made CO2
the other fifth of carbon emissions
comes from the burning down of
rainforests that's right one-fifth of
all human CO2 emissions are from
deforestation
to clear land for farming
cattle grazing
and expanding the cities
and whether the carbon is from a cold
plant in Indiana
or a raised rainforest in Indonesia
it heats the planet exactly the same
every year we destroy enough forests to
equal half the size of California or
Oklahoma and Maryland combined
or eight vermonts
[Music]
so protecting rainforests is a big deal
on the carbon Frontier
but what we learned next was a real kick
in the gut
even if we stopped all carbon emissions
today
the Earth will still continue to heat up
because
we've put too much CO2 up there
already
if you could split the atmosphere into
one million equal parts you would see
that very few parts would be made of
carbon dioxide that's why scientists
measure these tiny yet powerful amounts
of CO2 in parts per million
the safe level of carbon dioxide in the
atmosphere is around 350 parts per
million we are currently at 387 and that
means that we really have to get down to
zero emissions during this century and
we have to be well on the way by the
middle of a century
and secondly we've got to suck some
stuff out that we already put up there
and we've got to get on that path sooner
rather than later or we will pass this
point of no return this Tipping Point
Beyond which we can't actually fix the
problem things will spiral out of
control
[Music]
if we haven't already passed the Tipping
Point most scientists believe it's fast
approaching
once the booming economies of Brazil
Russia India and China take off
CO2 levels could easily get to 550 parts
per million or higher by 2050 and when
350 is considered the safe threshold and
hey even if you consider 450 a safe
threshold 550 is horrifying permafrost
melts releasing massive amounts of new
CO2 and methane
C is 20 feet higher a billion people
without fresh water
it could happen
if we do nothing you can bet on it
happening
but there is a solution
if we trust our planets five billion
years of research and development
and work in concert with nature
the land could revert to what it does
best
taking Airborne carbon and storing it
sequestering it back in our forests
farms and pastures
foreign
first we've got to stop burning down the
trees
a couple Solutions
in the Amazon a major cause of
deforestation is to clear grazing land
for beef cattle
and farmland to grow soy to feed the
cattle
if the meat eaters like myself go
meatless just one day a week it would
reduce not only huge amounts of CO2 but
also the powerful greenhouse gas methane
a byproduct of cow verbs
second eco-tourism
when people who live in or next to
rainforests make more money protecting
them
the rainforests stay
[Music]
in addition to forests Farms hold vast
potential for grabbing CO2 out of the
air and storing it in their soil
but alas most conventional Farmers have
yet to jump on the sequestering
bandwagon
generally a conventional Farm is set up
more like a factory the soil is the
factory farmers buy inputs whether
they're seeds fertilizers herbicides
pesticides and they bring those into the
factory the soil and they have product
going out the other end the problem with
that system is it's based on an
industrial model and we all know that
every Factory in every industry wears
out but when the soil wears out we're in
trouble but in organic farming systems
we're improving the soil and the health
of the soil while we're using it one of
the pieces that we're beginning to
understand about what happens in the
life of the soil is mycorrhizal fungi it
is a fungi that will attach itself to
the root hair and it creates a symbiotic
relationship with the plant the
mycorrhizal fungus is the main mechanism
by which carbon accumulates in the soil
not for a season not for tens of Seasons
not for hundreds of Seasons but up to
thousands of years these mycorrhizae
fungi flourish in organic systems
they're not as prevalent in conventional
systems so chemicals inhibit their
growth or sometimes like fumigants will
kill them another thing that kills the
fungi is leaving Fields fallow well we
happen to know here in our research is
is one of the best things you can do is
put in a winter cover crop what's really
important about this is it leaves a
place where this Michael rhizal fungi to
stay alive and grow and when we do that
we can literally sequester over one
thousand pounds of carbon per acre per
year
but the other really important piece to
this is cover cropping greatly reduces
the capacity for that soil to erode
because you have crop and root there to
hold it in wind or rain there's a lot of
carbon in soil preventing it from
eroding not only keeps enormous amounts
of carbon from being released the
resulting carbon-rich soil would retain
water and drought absorb water and flood
and produce healthier food
this is the beauty of what Organics
gives to the world it's actually as I
like to say it's biological it's a
regenerative approach to farming it's a
regenerative approach to taking carbon
dioxide out of the air and building soil
Health at the same time
[Music]
naturally grazed grasslands can also
reverse erosion and potentially
sequester huge amounts of carbon the
best soils are always produced naturally
under tall grasslands
I'll show you some of my favorite
grasses
here they are
this is a bunch grass that cows love it
it's an ice cream plant which means that
they will choose it over everything else
the grass co-evolved to be trampled
chewed
and left alone if you bite off the top
of the plant that much of the root dies
back I'm sure every plant's a little
different ratio but in that die off all
this material that has now been kind of
abandoned by the plant is food for the
mycorrhizal activity the bacteria that
is how soil gets built down there
the cow's manure also vastly increases a
healthy grassland's ability to sequester
carbon
but many grasslands are not healthy many
of our soils have been mistreated and
through compaction either from animals
humans or from Machinery develop what
are called plow pans which are very
thick compacted layers of clay that
cement together and don't allow the
roots to penetrate deeply in the soil
and the roots are the major plant organ
that is associated with soil Improvement
and carbon sequestration
so the carbon Farmers slice through the
compacted soil allowing the Grassroots
to grow three to eight feet bringing
tons of carbon down deep we want to be
having so much carbon sequester that we
actually have to hire people to burn
coal to get carbon dioxide back up into
the atmosphere because we went too far
and I see this as our version of a
victory garden
the whole world can do
[Music]
if we can achieve a major shift in
managing grasslands forests and Farms
then these natural land use practices
give us the potential to draw down 39 of
Mankind's current CO2 emissions
now this is new science to be sure but
the early numbers are tantalizing over
the next 50 years these game changers
could reduce atmospheric CO2 by 50 parts
per million in our dirty little hands is
an unheralded solution that could help
lead us back to the safe level of 350
parts per million foreign
if all these Solutions are such great
ideas why haven't they happened yet
because clean energies are at a
disadvantage
carbon emissions are causing climate
change which will cost trillions of
dollars to combat yet emitting carbon
costs nothing
now there's a powerful option for
getting Energy Efficiency and clean
energy to expand from less than two
terawatts to all 16.
foreign
we've got to find a way to give a common
set of incentives to people to reduce
the generation of greenhouse gases the
most efficient way to do that is to put
a price on carbon that can only be done
artificially by government Intervention
which means a bigger government hand on
the economy because the problem is not
going to go away otherwise
so you know we shouldn't think that this
problem will be solved by running out of
coal or gas or oil it will be solved by
addressing the emissions from coal and
gas and oil we need a powerful Market
signal that will tilt the whole system
away from where it is today where
pollution is free and everybody says hey
we'll just pollute to a whole new ball
game where pollution no longer is free
in fact it's more and more expensive and
anybody who's intelligent is going to
start polluting less
putting a price on carbon which is now
tepidly being tried in Europe and the
U.S is critical
the devil is in the details of how these
carbon laws are written we'd bore you to
tears with cap and trade versus carbon
tax debates
but either way an effective place to
focus is on carbon-based fuels at the
source
there's only a relatively small number
of companies oil companies Coal
companies natural gas companies who are
bringing carbon into the economy we can
make those suppliers pay for every ton
of carbon that is in the fuels that they
Supply and as the price of carbon goes
up dirty Technologies become more
expensive and it opens up a space for
clean Technologies to come in and
compete
so whether a price on carbon happens
soon or down the road
Forward Thinking companies are already
moving ahead as if carbon costs the
money then they're finding out it
actually does
the Walt Disney Company has created an
internal carbon tax making all divisions
pay for emitting carbon their carbon tax
inspires employees to use less energy
emit less carbon create more profit
since 1994 Dow Chemical has spent one
billion dollars on Energy Efficiency
so far Dao says it turned more than nine
billion dollars in Energy savings
and for the folks at Stonyfield Farm the
world's largest organic yogurt producer
it's become clear just as existing
buildings need to be retrofit existing
businesses need the same
we've found that we're actually turning
our operation Inside Out by empowering
the folks throughout the business to
drive out waste to drive out excess
carbon production
we had to build a waste treatment plant
because we had exceeded the capacity of
the local Wastewater system so the team
actually came up with an entirely
different approach that traps the gases
that are being created by the waste and
that gas has actually been used now to
actually operate the facility and so
they took something that was a cost
center and a pollution Center and turned
it into a profit Center which means this
thing is now making me money
the transportation team is an even
better example here they've reduced over
6 million Trucking miles that's a 60
percent carbon reduction
these teams together in the last three
years have generated 7.8 million dollars
of profits for my company that's 7.8
million dollars it translates into 46
new jobs and so even through the
recession we were growing jobs
so there's nothing that makes more sense
from an economic point of view than
reducing your carbon footprint
so let's say making economic sense is
the goal then the real work begins
intensifying Energy Efficiency standards
making clean energy cheaper than carbon
energy
giving the pentagons greenhawks a
megaphone
completely changing our land use
practices
this is going to be an engineering
political and Industrial Revolution
don't think big
think huge
I think what we have to understand is
that we're looking at a World War II
level of mobilization when the Japanese
attacked Pearl Harbor FDR said we're not
going to sell any more private cars
we're going to make the planes and the
tanks and the whatever we need to do to
win this war with claims for example the
goal is to produce sixty thousand people
who are very skeptical because no one
had ever seen arms production numbers
like that before and in the end we
produce not sixty thousand but 129 000
planes the key point there is it didn't
take decades to restructure the U.S
industrial economy it didn't take years
it was done in a matter of months
if we take that same level of enthusiasm
interest and focus in trying to come up
with sustainable initiatives and
renewable energy sources there's no
doubt in my mind we can achieve that
when we look back at World War II we
think of the greatest generation
tackling climate change calls for
Extraordinary Generations
let's get a look at Weston over here
we put solar panels in that's the
easiest way right now wind power isn't
very feasible in this area because
there's rarely enough wind all they've
been developing it's the sole arm wind
turbines which run on Lower amounts of
wind or instead of the traditional
blades it's a cylinder shape with
propellers on it so it spins
horizontally instead vertically like
this one thing's for sure the new
generation is ready to take the reins to
harvest the 16 terawatts of clean
climate safe sources from 86 000
terawatts of solar 32 terawatts of
geothermal at 870 terawatts of wind
power
for the current generation although some
will need a bit of prodding there are a
number of leaders as well
we need more
many more
[Music]
that's a shot right there that's it
they're putting the panels in
it's exciting this is what I've been
working for praying for I wish my dad
were here to see it
uh my dad passed away in May and um
he uh
great man so
so anyway I'm doing this for him and for
my son and it's uh this is the most
beautiful scene in the world
[Music]
right here
[Laughter]
[Music]
foreign
cause to address the climate change
problem ultimately I think it could be
one that reminds people of our common
Humanity
[Music]
we all agree that there is some aspect
of it that we can embrace the
environment the economy or national
security and we can all move forward
together with it
[Music]
all these crises have set into motion
something good people want to to turn
the ship around and that is what we have
to rely on the people awaken can do
Miracles and that's what we need that's
what we're going to get
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
when gamessa first decided to locate its
factories in Fairless Hills what was
here was a rusted out shell of a former
U.S steel facility that had been left
fallow for 15 years
then they refitted it and actually
brought jobs in as opposed to
Outsourcing which I really appreciate
and put a lot of Steel Workers back to
work Jim Bauer worked for U.S steel and
he was absolutely impacted by the Rust
Belt phenomena and he lost his job it's
a big happening in your life to be all
of a sudden found to be out of work and
trying to support the family and kids
going to school
let's talk I worked in a building next
door that is actually on the ground
right now the process of knocking it
down right now
am I supposed to be smoking on film my
white cheese if I'm in trouble
I worked all where you see that scrap
that's actual building and my cranes are
laying on the ground chopped up and it's
kind of sad really
it's been 25 years over here
maybe a commercial build a wind turbine
plant on this side too
this spot right here holds a very
special spot in my heart
right there
I fell over right here and had a heart
attack actually I looked up at this
Tower and everything got real mellow and
now I'm looking up at it again and the
wind's blowing real good and
I still have a hell of a future ahead of
me
our plant here last year produced about
500 turbines and we have created over a
thousand jobs and it's a story that can
be recreated throughout the United
States and that's what this is all about
we built the first major show we found
in the UK
my day job is I have to make money for
my business but it just does not get me
out of bed frankly and one of the best
antidotes for that that you know I've
found personally you know get out in a
boat and you look up at this thing it
goes beyond where we actually pay an ex
billion pounds profit last year so we
did that and the feeling that that
brings is just infectious you want to do
more of it
there's a piece
just standing here right now
particularly if you weren't here with
that camera
I bet if the camera wasn't here you know
if you weren't here with that camera if
I was here by myself okay
just standing here sitting here just
leaning up against that tree
it's a feeling I don't get very often I
put it that way I haven't had very often
in my life